2017 and Elon Musk was making headlines
hello I'm Elon Musk
[Music]
Elon Musk is possibly the greatest
living inventor he was well on his way
to becoming the richest person on the
planet Tessa stock was going to the Moon
he was publishing papers on his plans to
colonize Mars but he wasn't the only
musk making headlines in 2017. Elon
musk's
dad
who apparently had a kid recently that's
not the issue uh he's a 76 year old
Arrow musk uh no it's the issue is that
the mother of the child is his 35 year
old stepdaughter
she came a couple of months later told
me that she was pregnant so I said Well
it can't be me so uh you know I had a
test done and turned out yes I was the
father well Elon was off becoming a
modern day Titan his dad aeromus was
trending on Twitter why was elon's Dad
training on Twitter for having a child
with his stepdaughter who was more than
40 years younger than him pretty
disturbing after divorcing elon's mother
Arrow must remarried a woman named Haida
who already had two kids of her own one
of which was 4 year old Jana and for the
next 18 years aeromus and Haida were
happily married and they even had two
more kids together Arrow helped raise
his stepdaughter Yana they were family
but eventually their marriage fell apart
and the pair went their own ways it
wouldn't be until many years later that
Arrow would reconnect with his
stepdaughter Yana but this time things
got weird I never saw Jana for years and
then in about 2014 which is about years
later
she contacted me to say she's desperate
you know the next day I rushed to go and
find I started helping her besides to
become really close and um you know
um
I like her very much and she had uh yeah
and some little boy here according to
Errol his stepdaughter Yana came to him
in shambles after a breakup with her
boyfriend and as ELO's dad attempted to
comfort her it just sort of happened
elon's Dad just kind of slept with his
own stepdaughter and boom their son was
accidentally conceived Arrow said it
quote happened in the Heat of the Moment
End quotes and so the stepfather step
daughter Duo gave birth to their son
Elliot Rush elon's dad Arrow was 71 at
the time and Jana barely 30. but the
story doesn't end there less than two
years later they ended up having another
child this time a girl to say that Arrow
must has five other adult children were
upset at this Revelation was an
understatement Arrow told the media that
quote his kids still don't like it they
still feel creepy about it because she's
their sister their half-sister End
quotes but Arrow was downplaying hits
his kids were Furious especially Elon
Elon already had a rocky relationship
with his father since he was a kid but
this this was the nail in the coffin
because according to Elon his father
aeromus is literally evil and this was
far from the first questionable thing
he's done he was such a terrible human
being
um yeah my dad will have a carefully
thought out plan of evil he will plan
evil and once you learn the truth behind
who the Billionaire's father really is
and the things that he's done you might
end up agreeing with them stay dangerous
subscribe for more and this is the dark
story of the man that gave birth to the
one and only Elon Musk
is great
Elon Musk is insanely productive and you
want to know what else is very
productive 15 minutes with today's
sponsor blinkist blinkist allows you to
understand the most important things
from over 5 500 non-fiction books and
podcasts in just 15 minutes they've got
titles like Atomic habits and how to win
friends and influence people and you can
access them in both text and audio
formats I use blinkist to quickly check
out books that I think would be a great
fit for me before actually buying and
committing to the entire book there's no
fluff with blinkist and this has
literally saved me hundreds of hours of
my time I also use blinkist to refresh
my memory on books I've read already for
example if you're great at starting
things but have problems following
through I recommend the dip by Seth
Garden super great title highly
recommend blinkist also has this cool
new social feature called blinkus spaces
which allows you to recommend books and
blinks to your friends and family so
whether you want to improve yourself or
level up your entire family pause the
video scroll down and click the link
below blinkist.com jaketran to get a
free 7-Day trial and 25 off your annual
subscription that's blinkist.com for a
free 7 day trial and 25 off premium
thanks to blankets for sponsoring this
video
aeromus was a very complicated man long
before he had a child with a
stepdaughter but to be honest what would
you expect from the Elon musk's father
Errol you are the father of the richest
man in the world does that sit
comfortably with you well yes you know I
Pro I think I said 20 years ago at least
20 years ago I said Elon won't stop
until he's number one Errol grew up in
Pretoria South Africa with his father
who was an Army Sergeant and his British
mother his mom came from a family that
was well known for their intelligence
and apple didn't fall too far from the
tree according to Elon himself his dad
was the man he got his engineering
Brilliance from Aero has an insanely
high IQ and built up many successful
businesses just like his billionaire son
I'm naturally good at engineering that's
because I inherited it from my father
what's very difficult for others is easy
for me
for a while I thought things were so
obvious that everyone must know this he
lost that was even the youngest person
to get a professional engineering
qualification in South Africa but elon's
that wasn't nearly as good with his
personal relationships Arrow was the
type of guy who wouldn't stop until he
got what he wanted so when he crossed
paths with the gorgeous may heldman he
knew he had to have her she was a
supermodel dietitian and the wife ever
always imagined for himself but may
didn't feel the same At first she turned
him down so many times but Arrow pursued
her relentlessly telling elon's
biographer Ashley Vance he just never
stopped proposing Arrow would wear her
down until she finally said yes to his
marriage proposal the two got married
and just nine months after their wedding
their lives would change forever when
they had their first son Elon Reeve Musk
from early on everyone could tell that
there was something special about Elon
was there a moment that you remember
during his childhood where you went yep
there's something special about this kid
there's something different well yes you
know I mean he was obviously very bright
as a child and um you know he would uh
yeah he had plenty of plenty of ideas he
knew all about what uh computers were
were capable of when he was about 11. he
has always been a very deep thinker when
he was very small for example he would
ask me uh where is the whole world
Elon was just different because it was
clear that other people did not
would their mind wasn't exploding with
ideas Eli's parents would go on to have
two more children and for a few years
everything went well aeromus was already
a millionaire by the time he turned 30
he allegedly accumulated his fortune
from his engineering business and later
he earned even more money by owning half
of an emerald mine operation Arrow said
they had so much money that at one point
they couldn't even close their safe the
musk family were among the richest
families in the city owning one of the
biggest houses in all of Pretoria they
were well loved by the community and
arrow was even elected to the Pretoria
city council where he advocated for
abolishing apartheid the family traveled
around the world and got an incredible
education but while they seemed like the
perfect family on the outside behind
closed doors thanks for it nearly as
picture perfect his parents marriage
tumultuous yeah Harold was allegedly
abusive alleged except for that kind of
abuse yes yeah yeah I think I was I was
beaten up but the thing is and you know
there was a saying in South Africa when
you get divorced you stop falling in the
shower because every time you hear scene
with bruises you said you fell in the
shower yeah so there was it was a common
saying in South Africa when I was
married I was told about three times a
day that I'm boring and stupid and you
know and ugly and and and if I protested
then I got beaten up eventually they
couldn't keep it together any longer
arrow and may got the voice when Elon
was just eight years old and that's when
things got complicated for the
father-son duo he lost two younger
siblings elected to live with their mom
but when ilas Allah his dad was going to
be left all alone he felt guilty I felt
sorry for my father because my mother
had all three kids
he seemed very sad and lonely by himself
so he decided to move in with his father
to keep him company and it ended up
being one of the worst decisions of his
entire life yeah I I was sad for my
father but I didn't really understand at
the time what kind of person he was it
was not a good idea
Elon is very secretive about exactly
what happened to him during the years he
lived with his father as a child all we
know is that according to Elon it
plunged him into a quote personal Dark
Age at only 10 years old it wouldn't be
until years later that Elon would learn
just how ruthless his father could be
foreign
it's 1998 Errol musk was checking in on
an empty rental property that he owned
in Johannesburg South Africa and with
them was a six-year-old daughter Ali
they arrived at the property around 5 PM
when Ali told her dad she wanted to take
a bath but as Arrow was trying to look
for a towel for her to use that's when
he was confronted by something
terrifying standing in the lounge area
of the home were seven burglars staring
straight back at him and the second the
Intruder saw him they opened firewood No
Remorse Arrow ran back to the main
bedroom to grab his 357 Magnum after
gunshots went off Ali ran up 100 dead
naked and cold and hid behind his leg
while she was next to me during the
whole thing she clung onto me like a
monkey but kept quiet she didn't scream
or cry End quotes and as soon as Arrow
had his gun in his hand he did not waste
any time well I took the first guy out
through the head when he got back into
the hallway one of The Intruders stood
with his gun pointed straight at him and
they both shot at the same time so I hit
him in the groin and I thought he had
hit me I looked down to see where our
shots but Arrow wasn't hits Arrow's life
was narrowly saved by a partially opened
door just in front of him as soon as the
rest of the burglars realized that Arrow
was a sharpshooter they've ran for the
hills Arrow ended up killing three of
The Intruders in total and after the
horrifying ordeal he took his daughter
Ali to see a trauma psychologist to cope
she told the therapist she felt okay
about the shooting quote because my dad
won End quotes era would end up being
booked on manslaughter charges and went
on trial for the incidents luckily Arrow
must have plenty of money for lawyers he
played his self-defense and ended up
getting off on all charges and as an
outsider looking in if all of this is
true then I applaud elon's dad in this
specific case but Elon felt differently
to him it made him see his dad in a
whole new lights I think unlike
Wikipedia it says that I was inspired by
my father in terms of Technology this is
not the this is actually not true I
think it needs to be corrected it was
never a seaweed that Elon wasn't very
tight with his father but in 2017 Elon
made it very clear to the public just
how much he really despised them Elon
sat down for a tell-all interviewer
Rolling Stone where he dug deep into his
past and his relationship with his
father and he had some very Illuminating
thoughts to share about Errol quote he
was such a terrible human being you have
no idea how bad it was almost every
crime you can possibly think of he has
done almost every evil thing you could
possibly think of he has done it's so
terrible you can't believe it end quotes
elon's voice trembled as he told the
interviewer quote my dad will have a
carefully thought out plan of evil he
will plan evil in quotes and as Elon
recalled his true feelings about his dad
tears began silently pouring down his
cheeks Eli quickly wiped away his tears
and said I can't remember the last time
I cried this interview painted a pretty
compelling picture the stoic Elon Musk
had never broken his calm cool and
collected demeanor before but just at
the mere mention of how he feels about
his dad he broke down in tears what are
the evil things that Arrow did Elon
would not specify but if we had to guess
Elon kept using the word evil and the
most evil thing that I can think of is
something that has to do with kids Elon
said that he tried to mend his
relationship with his dad many times he
even moved second wife and their kiss to
Malibu to be closer to him he bought
them a house a boat and as many cars as
they needed but it was futile quote in
my experience there is nothing you can
do nothing I wish I've tried everything
I've tried threats rewards intellectual
arguments emotional arguments everything
to try to change my father for the
better and it just got worse End quotes
but Arrow must didn't just roll over and
let Elon call him out nope he was just
as vocal about his feelings for his son
foreign
[Music]
most parents dream of racing a
billionaire like Elon Musk but Arrow
isn't impressed especially after Elon
exposed into the Press Arrow believed
that Elon decided to do the Rolling
Stone interview because he had a baby
with his former stepdaughter what a
terrible thing for Elon to do so Arrow
thought the only way to fight fire was
with fire so he started doing some
interviews of his own he told the press
that Elon was basically a bratty child
well I'm not gonna wait until he comes
to his senses he said Elon is having a
tantrum like a spoiled child Arrow let
everyone know that elon's childhood
couldn't have been that bad because they
were Filthy Rich I drove them to school
in a convertible Rolls Royce they had
thoroughbred horses to ride and
motorbikes at the age of 14. they were
spoiled I suppose maybe that's why Elon
is acting like a spoiled child now
but Arrow didn't stop there a few years
later he had this to say about his son
again you know you probably sick and
tired of hearing like you're like you're
probably a great guy too why is everyone
keep talking about your son yeah where
did he get it from is it you did he get
the genius side from you or was it mum
when they got into the meat of the
interview Errol was asked a simple
question are you proud of your son his
response left even the interviewer is
totally stunned are you proud did you
ever see that coming what you're not
proud no well you know I mean we are a
family that have been doing a lot of
things for a long time no elon's dad is
not proud of perhaps one of the most
important individuals of Our Generation
instead he has a lot more affection for
elon's little brother Kimball you know
my younger son is also a billionaire
although he's only a single billionaire
I mean one billion but anyway the point
is do you tease him and say gee you're a
disappointment for younger you've only
got one billion
for all his accomplishments money and
fame Elon Musk still can't win the
approval of his father even after Eli
had been financially supporting his
father for decades in a 2022 tweet Elon
said Arrow ran out of money in the 90s
my brother and I financially supported
him and his extended family in South
Africa since then on the condition that
he not do bad things
unfortunately he did do bad things right
now Elon is going to war against open AI
when push comes to shove let's say they
do create some some digital super
intelligence almost Godlike intelligence
well who's in control and one
revolutionary AI development that just
happened that you need to know about is
this check it out we're stuck on this
stupid Tower in the middle of
nowhere and I don't blame you and now
we're stuck on this stupid
[Music]
stuck on this stupid freaking Tower in
the middle of freaking nowhere
and it's all my fault
yesterday
and you can learn more about this in our
new video on our new channel Alpha
signal Alpha Sonos started off as the
biggest AI research newsletter out there
read by researchers from these places
which is great and all but that meant
the newsletter was kind of hard to
understand from the average person so we
came together and decided to launch the
official YouTube channel for it so that
you can stay on top of the latest in AI
where videos that even a 5 year old can
understand so click the card on the
screen to watch now
thank you
[Music]
foreign